Gant Gong defeat Godzilla the fight of
the century Kong vs. Godzilla it's a
fight we've all been waiting for
Godzilla
argh who believe the king of the monster
verse and everyone's favorite after he
laid waste to King Ghidorah whereas
comedy @n is also a fan favorite more
related to us humans and a benevolent
God worship other people of Skull Island
and King Kong vs. Godzilla 1962 calm won
the fight against Godzilla although it
is not shown whether Godzilla just got
fed up and swam away oh then he died
but who will win in the next clash this
is up to Adam Wingard personally I would
have liked to see a calm versus behemoth
battle seems more appropriate but are we
so sure that these two will face each
other after seeing other several titles
and king of the monsters there is a
chance that these two might be teaming
up to face against those other
classified titles and maybe legendary
would sign a deal for another deadly
title to be introduced maybe the idea of
Kong vs. Godzilla is attractive but
there is no question that Gong is facing
an uphill battle in this this one
legendary Godzilla comes in and around
393 feet or 120 meters in height and
weighs a hundred thousand tons he is an
alpha predator with every inch of his
body modeled for battle not only to
mention his atomic breath and that he
could turn himself into a thermonuclear
device that can send several million
degrees shockwaves like we have seen in
king of the monsters final battle gone
on the other hand is a hundred foot tall
gorilla ish Titan that is not even
one-third of Godzilla's total height and
his weight is as properly estimated by
fans as no more than a thousand tons
which is what percent of the weight of
the big G now let's put these two into
perspective Gong in the 2017 Skull
Island movie set in the 1970s
gone was still described as an
adolescent ape by 2020 he will be fully
grown and possibly needs to triple in
size to fit against a fight against
Godzilla this might be real as it is
teased that car might face a radioactive
source that would reshape and spur his
growth even though he weighs less his
belt and physique shows that shows that
he is not only faster but more agile in
the fight being able to
react quicker his opposable thumbs and
toes means that he can use both hands
and feet as weapons
his main advantage though is is high
intelligence don't get me wrong Godzilla
is smart but still subject to his
instincts whereas calm has evolved to a
higher degree where he can devise and
use weapons Godzilla the big G comes in
out of way bigger size and heavier scale
than Gong even if Gong dribbles in
height estimates would put a 300 feet
calm at between 10,000 and 20,000 tons
which is roughly 10 to 20 percent the
weight of Titan is Gojira his entire
body has been shaped over millions of
years of exposure and feeding off of
radiation to become an impenetrable
armor from head to toe to the tip of the
tail his entire body is a weapon his
atomic breath is his main weapon that
can melt Gong a mammalian body of Gong
would not be able to endear thousands of
degrees of atomic dragon breath if Gor
made a fatal mistake the last thing is
that nukes only make him stronger
imagine a media explosion did nothing to
him except make him stronger
what would a few punches and kicks do oh
yes
the super Godzilla transformation in
king of the monsters Godzilla turned
himself into a nuclear bomb and emitted
a powerful atomic pulse which melted
King Ghidorah in just a matter of
seconds even though his transformation
is highly unlikely to happen again due
to factors like nuking him and motherís
life energy combining would only become
lazy writing if they are repeated it
just shows to you the intensity of
Godzilla's power it was mentioned that
Skull Island supposedly has focus of
hidden radiation that could make Kampf
bigger but then again Godzilla absorbs
radiation and heals from it this is
established in every incarnation of
Godzilla law and history this would only
serve to make Godzilla even stronger if
he got to the source if we remember in
Skull Island gone almost lost to the
giant skull crawler if it wasn't for the
help of the humans it's become a running
justification and analyst comb grows to
triple his size in 50 years gross armor
miraculously evolves new powers new
defenses and becomes a completely
different creature algae altogether in
every way then it might be a closer
fight well
isn't Godzilla versus calm anymore is it
it's Godzilla versus a brand-new monster
created specifically to give Godzilla
small challenge we have completely
reinventing calm in every conceivable
way and there is no possibility cog
could survive more than seconds
literally and that is with Godzilla just
standing on the same island the
conclusion well by now we know who the
Alpha is and who is still on top of the
throne if you have any theory or
theories on how come and humiliate
Godzilla please leave it in the comment
section below so again do like share
subscribe and also click on the
notification bell for regular and actual
notifications